a would-be dogfight turns into a group
hug and Democrats impeachment efforts
move forward i'm ben shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show this show is sponsored
by expressvpn stop putting your online
data at risk get protected at expressvpn
dot-com
slash Penn ok so last night was the big
democratic debate it was gonna be
Rock'em Sock'em robots I had predicted
many attacks on Elizabeth Warren I had
predicted that booty judge would go
after Warren and maybe claw I
would go after booty judge and everybody
would go after ya none of that happen
instead they just massaged each other's
shoulders and this is horrible strategy
if you are at the bottom of this pack if
you are Cory Booker for example or
Kamala Harris if you're one of these
characters who literally has no shot of
winning the nomination then why are you
sitting around waiting what are you
waiting for like if you're if you're
Kamala Harris and you're best known for
cackling like a hyena why exactly would
you be sitting around waiting for
everybody to sort of come around to you
if you're Cory Booker why would you just
be Stan I mean I understand Cory Booker
is actually running for vice president
at this point he has no shot at the
nomination we all get that but even if
you're one of the top candidates why are
you not jockeying for position it is
bewildering to me particularly because
Elizabeth Warren is incredibly
vulnerable so I understand why bootie
judge didn't go after Warren he's rising
Warren's falling he feels like if I
attack Warren there's really no upside
for me what I don't understand is why
Warren isn't attacking Buddha judge
because Buddha judge is taking away her
support not Joe Biden's support now
maybe she's perceiving this thing wrong
maybe Elizabeth Warren thinks that
Peabody judge is the one who is grabbing
a bite in support but that is not
actually true it's not actually true why
is Bernie Sanders not going after Warren
but if he wants to regain any sort of
mojo here he has to take back the
Elizabeth Warren crowd and bring it back
into his calm cuz he ain't going nowhere
he is not running first in Iowa he is
not running first in New Hampshire he is
running first zero states 0 places he's
running third to fourth nationally so
what does Bernie Sanders doing instead
they all get up there and they just hug
it out man they just hug it out
because I suppose they think at this
point better to sort of be in a holding
pattern right it's still early we still
have three months until Iowa maybe they
think okay well if we just wait this
thing out then the field will sort of
itself out whatever was it was overall a
very boring debate I don't think that
anything really changed but it was as
usual an ad for Donald Trump it was an
advert Ahnold Trump because the
Democrats policies are so radical
they are so wild and these candidates
are incredibly incredibly off-putting
the more people see of Elizabeth Warren
the less they like her the more people
see of people who judge the more they
like him except when he actually reveals
his true face which is that he's an
extraordinarily radical candidate and he
doesn't like to reveal that too often he
made that mistake early in the campaign
he campaigned as a moderate started to
rise move to the left and then
immediately fell his campaigning is a
moderate again is starting to rise again
but whenever people see the real people
who to judge it's a problem the good
news for people to judge is that Peabody
Judge is able to mask that really well
Joe Biden everybody knows who he is so
there's a lot of talk today about Joe
Biden falling down on the job Joe Biden
having a bad debate and the reason
people are saying that Joe Biden had a
bad debate is because Joe Biden was
basically some ambulance during this
during this entire primary season right
he's basically a sleepwalker he's just
he's he's comatose he is not alive I
mean he's if you shot electricity
through his body perhaps he would move I
mean that really is sort of the that's
the rip puncher but that's all priced in
at this point and then Bernie Sanders
just Bernie Sanders he'll always be
Bernie Sanders a hundred years from now
Bernie Sanders will be Bernie Sanders
because he always was Bernie Sanders
he's the high school principal from Back
to the Future that dude never had hair
Bernie Sanders was always a crazed old
loon bag even when he was 25 so did
anything change last night the answer
really is no but the people that helps
our Budaj Edge and Biden it does not
help Warren it does not help Sanders
okay so with all of that said let's get
into what was actually said during this
incredibly incredibly overall boring
debate so first off there there's the
moderators are just terrible because
it's an MSNBC debate that means that
every single question is basically a
kiss-ass question Oh could you possibly
be more wonderful Oh could you possibly
tell us why you're so wonderful now Fox
News gets a lot of flack for being
biased when Fox News helped presidential
primary debates in 2016 it created all
sorts of controversy and all sorts of
heat so much so that Donald Trump
actually skipped one of the debates
because he didn't want megyn kelly
asking him questions you will never see
a Democrat skip one of these debates
because the only
they have a chance of missing it's an
ice cream cone handed them by Rachel
Maddow that is the only thing that they
like none of them have to fear being
asked a tough question by Rachel Maddow
none zero so here is just just to prove
my point here is a quick montage not
caught by us stop by was washington free
beacon somebody kind of quick montage of
this of all of the moderator questions
last night or many of the moderator
questions last night and i mean they
brought their massage oils with them and
listen to these questions how central
should the president's conduct uncovered
by this impeachment inquiry they to any
Democratic nominees campaign for
president how central would it be to
yours for a recently told Congress quote
the majority of the domestic terrorism
cases that we've investigated are
motivated by white supremacist violence
congresswoman Gabbard to you as
president would you direct the federal
government to do something about this
problem that it is not currently doing
Vice President Biden you suggested in
your campaign that if you defeat
President Trump Republicans will start
working with Democrats again but right
now Republicans in Congress including
some of whom you've worked with for
decades are demanding investigations not
only of you but also of your son okay so
now also every single question is could
you possibly be more if our left like
let's just push you to the left push
shoots and left so that's what the
debate was last night
which is why sort of ended up with this
whole kumbaya Amanda listen CNN got a
lot of flack in the debates that were
held before this one for supposedly
contributing to the candidates attacking
each other that is the only purpose of a
debate the only purpose of a debate is
to highlight differences between the
candidates now to highlight similarities
between the candidates but MSNBC because
it is an insane ridiculous network
decides that instead the purpose of the
debate should basically be generalized
kiss a sory and demonstrating the unity
of the Democratic Party in the face of
Donald Trump yeah we know they don't
like Trump if anything was illuminated
last night I'm waiting to hear it
well done Andrea Mitchell and Rachel
Matt what a joke what a joke by the way
when Republicans hosted debates in it
went when when Republicans had a debate
in 2016 and Fox News was hosting the
debates there was no point at which Sean
Hannity was one of the hosts of the
debate Rachel Maddow is Sean Hannity the
the Fox News team used martha maccallum
the
bret baier and these megan kelly at no
point did they call in Sean Hannity yka
Sean is a partisan an open partisan well
Rachel Maddow is an open partisan and
bringing in Rachel Maddow to play this
game is just ridiculous
so obviously nothing new was learned
last night who's supposed to be a
showpiece for the candidates instead and
it ended up being an incredibly boring
affair with with really very few punches
thrown except for the punches that Joe
Biden threw it himself but we're all
used to those at this point okay we'll
get to the actual content of what the
candidates had to say in just one moment
first let's talk about a fantastic
phenomenal gift you can get for somebody
this holiday season I am talking about
the gift of preserving their memories
there's very little in life that really
I truly believe this is important
there's very little in life that is more
important than preserving all of your
family memories
I've got kids and all of the pictures
that we take that we put on the on the
phone and that are digitally available
really convenient for me but what about
all the pictures from when I was a kid
my parents can't really look at those
cuz they're all out in the garage or
there are on old VHS tapes they no
longer have a VCR well if you got
parents and yeah grandparents and you
got old film reels in the garage why not
get all that stuff digitized so now it's
accessible and now in case god forbid
there's a fire or a flood or something
you're not trying to slap mold ridden
boxes out of your garage and say just
grab a thumb drive and you're done right
that is what legacy box does the legacy
box allows you to take their legacy box
kit fill it up with all your stuff send
it to them and then in a couple of weeks
you get all your originals back plus
perfectly preserved digitally to watch
share and relive get started preserving
your past today go to legacy box comm
slash pens get 40% off your first order
save your time and your memories go to
legacy box comm slash Ben save 40%
legacy box comm slash Ben and get that
special deal save that 40% makes a great
holiday gift by the way okay so the
debate begins and the beginning of the
debate is all about how Donald Trump is
a big mean very bad man who's very mean
so Elizabeth Warren leads the way and
she is just irritating she's irritating
Amy Klobuchar is clova chair is is
certainly not as irritating as Elizabeth
Warren on the other hand Kamala Harris
is significantly more irritating than
Elizabeth Warren but Elizabeth Warren is
an irritating human being her faux
sincerity really great okay so I'm very
friendly with Senator Ted Cruz but
during the 2016 campaign there is no
question that senator Cruz came off as
insane
here in his FX right it's just a problem
that senator Cruz has in his effect when
he speaks on stage Elizabeth Warren has
the exact same problem the exact same
problem except more so like she appears
to be trying too hard at nearly every
point
so here's Elizabeth Warren talking about
constitutional principle the same lady
who says she's gonna propose a 2% wealth
tax which is utterly unconstitutional
it is completely unconstitutional pay
for all of her programs with a tax that
is not available under the Constitution
article 1 section 9 if she's wildly
disingenuous but here she is talking
about the value of the Constitution that
she cares so deeply about we have to
establish the principle no one is above
the law we have a constitutional
responsibility and we need to meet it oh
well the enthusiasm the fake enthusiasts
so my favorite answer to the how bad is
Donald trum question came from Amy
Klobuchar who decided you know be
worthwhile I'm gonna quote Jimmy Carter
the worst president of the last 50 years
to talk about honor and dignity and
integrity a guy was ousted from office
after he's the only president of the
last 50 years now stood from office
after one term with no huge third-party
threat like Ross Perot in the wings here
is Amy club club HR citing Jimmy Carter
as an inspiration I was thinking about
this when I was at the Carter
Presidential Museum and on the wall or
etched the words of Walter Mondale when
he looks back at their four years not
perfect and he said this we told the
truth we obeyed the law we kept the
peace we told the truth we obeyed the
law we kept the peace that is the
minimum that we should expect in a
President of the United States thank you
wow it's corny Jimmy Carter okay now the
person who had the best answer to this
question was people who to judge so the
person that people who judged campaigns
as when he's pretending is actually
pretty attractive right people judge
campaigns as obama circa 2008 before a
lot of the racial politics entered into
his presidency and his campaign the i'm
a great unifier i'm gonna bring
everybody together we're gonna sing
kumbaya we're gonna have unity again
higher principles this is p buddha judge
doing this routine and doing it pretty
well here's clip three running to be the
president for that day the sun comes up
and the trump presidency is behind us
which will be at ten
moment in the life of this country and
we are going to have to unify a nation
that will be as divided as ever and
while doing it address big issues that
didn't take a vacation for the
impeachment process or for the Trump
presidency as a whole climate
approaching the point of no return the
fact that we've still got to act on
health care kids learning active shooter
drills before they learn to read and an
economy where even when the Dow Jones is
looking good far too many Americans have
to fight like hell just to hold on to
what they've got okay Buddha judge is
very good at this
the reason Budi judge is very good at
this is because the question was about
Trump but he made the answer about what
he's going to do as president beyond
trumpets actually got very smart tactic
as opposed to Elizabeth Warren who went
into battle battle militant mode and Amy
Klobuchar who is citing Jimmy Carter or
something
Buddha judge says no we're gonna have
this moment and then I'm gonna unify the
country now Joe Biden's response okay
this was his very first answer his
opening statement okay Joe Biden says
the right thing but he looks as though
he is actively going to collapse on the
stage he looks as though he is going to
actually faceplant he's gonna be one of
those comedy movies where the person
just stops clutches their chests and
keels over here is Joe Biden's opening
statement he says something true but he
also happens to be experiencing some
sort of trouble well you have to ask
yourself up here who is most likely to
be able to win the nomination in the
first place you have to win the
presidency in the first place and
secondly who is most likely to increase
the number of people who are Democrats
in the House in the Senate okay and I
mean he was like this the whole debate
he couldn't get through a sentence
without stumbling because he's not gonna
get through a sentence without stumbling
so just from those opening statements
buta judge is the best at this and budda
judge has has not had a bad debate yet
rhyming Buddha judge has really
performed well in these debates
circumstances they're almost tailor-made
for him he is smooth he never gives a
straight answer he's quite good at this
also when you contrast him with Warren
again he looks much more attractive than
Warren as a candidate to sort of the
general population and particularly
people in the swing states the reason
for that is because Elizabeth Warren has
decided that she's going to run
full-scale hardcore progressive and
alienate as many people as she can so
the candidates were asked about
unity this is a question tailor-made for
booty dredge but Warren has asked about
unity and her answer about unity is I am
going to cram taxes down your throat and
I'm gonna say that if you built a
business in this country it's cuz
there's a road in front of your business
but that was he that was considered a
GAF by Barack Obama in 2012 people
forget this because Romney lost the
election but in 2012 when Barack Obama
did the whole you didn't build that and
then cited Elizabeth Warren's idiotic
2011 speech where she suggested that the
reason that your business is successful
is because we have a public school
system well that doesn't explain why
many businesses are not successful well
Elizabeth Warren just says it straight
out she's asked how are you gonna unify
the country she says I'm gonna I'm gonna
go to the rich people's houses and I'm
gonna rob their safes basically this is
not it this is not a good answer doing a
Wells tax is not about punishing anyone
it's about saying you built something
great in this country good for you but
you did it using workers all of us help
pay to educate you did it using you're
getting your goods to run roads and
bridges all of us help pay for it did it
protected my police and firefighters all
of us helped pay the salaries for so
when you make it bid when you make it
really big when you make a top one-tenth
of 1% big pitch in two cents so
everybody else gets a chance to make it
even here's the thing that's something
that Democrats care about independents
care about and Republicans care about
okay well no I'm sorry that that is not
what's gonna unify the country ripping
on rich people is not going to unify the
country and it is absurd to claim that
it will and you'll see Cory Booker kind
of mildly knocks her on this and of
course is exactly correct we'll get to
that in just one second first let us
talk about the fact that your
constitutional freedoms are under attack
from the left they are well one of those
constitutional freedoms perhaps the most
important constitutional freedom is the
right to keep and bear arms the founders
certainly saw this as pivotal because
this allowed you to protect your rights
allowed you to exercise your natural
right of self-defense the left wants to
rip that away from you this is why I am
a gun owner that's why so many Americans
are gun owners owning a rifle is an
awesome responsibility building rifles
is no different start in a garage buy a
Marine veteran more than two decades ago
bravo company manufacturing vcm for
short builds a professional-grade
product built to combat standards bravo
company manufacturing is not a sporting
arms company they design engineer
and manufacture life-saving equipment
the people at BCM assume that when a
rifle leaves their shop it will be used
in a life-or-death situation by a
responsible citizen law enforcement
officer or a soldier overseas to learn
more about bravo company manufacturing
head on over to bravo company MFG comm
you can discover more about their
products special offers and upcoming
news that's Bravo Company MFG comm if
you need more convincing find out even
more about BCM and awesome people who
make their products at youtube.com slash
bravo company USA and they are awesome
folks may I know them they make great
products check them out at Bravo Company
MFG calm patriotic many of them veterans
Bravo Company MFG Khan they are awesome
ok so Cory Booker comes back at
Elizabeth Warren and he points out your
tax system is idiotic we as Democrats
need to fight for a just taxation system
but as I travel around the country we
Democrats also have to talk about how to
grow wealth as well the idea behind what
is fair today the 99% in America are on
track to pay about 7.2 percent of their
total wealth in taxes not just really
top one-tenth of one percent that I want
to say pages and it's more they'll pay
3.2 percent in America
I'm tired of freeloading billionaires ok
she's tired of freeloading billionaires
tired of freeloading billionaires
billionaires are not freeloading they're
the ones paying the best quantity of
taxes beyond their ownership of the
wealth percentage it's what is she
talking about this is her remember the
original question was about unifying
people the original question was about
unifying people giant giant fail for
Elizabeth Warren pee poo to judge by
contrast can use Warren as a point of
contrast right Buddha judge can actually
put Warren over here and then say okay
here's what disunity looks like and I
represent unity here's people to judge
again doing this routine well here's
clip 7 and I believe that commanding
people to accept that option whether we
wait three years as Senator Warren has
proposed or whether you do it right out
of the gate is not the right approach to
unify the American people around a very
very big transformation that we now have
an opportunity to deliver okay so you
know again Budaj edge against Warren
looks much better to the general
population then Elizabeth Warren does
and this was her
throughout the campaign she started off
as a person who always had a plan and
now she's the person who's basically
Bernie Sanders but spelled out longer
and less honest and this irritates
Sanders to no end by the way and she's
asked about her health care plan and
Bernie Sanders is standing over here
going she ripped me off man like why is
everyone talking about Elizabeth
Warren's health care plan
I know Warren has asked about her dumb
health care plan which she originally
suggested Medicare for all then she
walked it back and said oh no no no
we'll do sort of Medicare for some and
then after three years we'll have a
referendum on it and Bernie Sanders is
asked about this clip 9 and Bernie
Sanders is just like why didn't you ask
me about this in the first place
I'm the one who originated this Sanders
let me bring you into this color
okay so again he has every reason to be
irritated now Joe Biden Joe Biden like
Buddha judges running on a more moderate
sort of platform and Biden hits Warren
here and this this attack is going to
continue to resonate because her plan
continues to be bad
here is Joe Biden talking about Medicare
for all in why see try and fail you know
we can do this without charging people
raising thirty forty trillion dollars
the fact is that right now the vast
majority Democrats do not support
Medicare for all it couldn't pass the
United States Senate right now with
Democrats it couldn't pass the House
Nancy Pelosi is one of those people who
then thinks makes sense okay so this is
a this is a telling attack now well all
of this was going on at the top of the
field meanwhile they're a bunch of
sideshows that were happening the most
the most kind of pyrotechnic sideshow
was this hit a tap between tete-a-tete
rather between tit for tat Teddy tat
between Tulsi Gabbard and Kamala Harris
when Tulsi Gabbard went after the
Democratic Party broadly speaking and
then Camilla Harris went after Tulsi
Gabbard it was amusing but has very
little impact on the race Connell Harris
is going nowhere by attacking Tulsi
Gabbard Norah's Tulsi Gabbard going
anywhere by attacking Kamala Harris here
is Tulsi Gabbard ripping on the
Democratic Party and then camel hair is
coming bad at back at her but our
Democratic Party unfortunately is not
the party that is of by and for the
people it's at a party it is a party
that has been and continues to be
influenced by the foreign policy
establishment in Washington represented
by Hillary Clinton and others foreign
policy by the military-industrial
complex and other greedy corporate
interests okay and then Camilla Harris
comes right back at her and suggests
that she's basically a closeted
Republican who's just doing this for the
press as opposed to Camilla Harris who's
a closeted crazy person who's just doing
this for the press
here's Carla Harris going after Tulsi
Gabbard I think it's unfortunate that we
have someone on this stage who is
attempting to be the Democratic nominee
for president of the United States who
during the Obama administration spent
four years full-time on Fox News credit
sizing President Obama criticizing
people on this stage as affiliated with
the Democratic Party when Donald Trump
was elected not even sworn in buddied up
to Steve Bannon to get a meeting with
Donald Trump in the Trump Tower fails to
call a war criminal by what he is as a
war criminal and then spends full time
during the course of this campaign again
criticizing the Democratic Party okay
again in common law Harris is gonna win
no points with the audience for going
after Tulsi Gabbard and Tulsi is happy
to take it cuz she ain't going anywhere
in this race rain she's not gonna be the
Democratic nominee maybe she'll run as
an independent or something being
attacked by common-law Harris is not the
worst thing to happen to her okay so
then we get to the actual the Democrats
radical proposals okay and the radical
proposals are just insane this is
particularly true when you get to their
proposals on climate change which bear
no relation to reality at all in any way
this is also true a foreign policy right
so so far this has sort of been a
personality battle the MSNBC anchors
wanted to make sure that the Democrats
were never asked specific questions
about their plans because the more
specific the plans get the worse
Americans like them and you can see this
from the left-wing websites that cover
the debates the left-wing websites that
cover the debates they are firmly
focused on we can't have another one of
these debates guys where we talk about
Medicare for all it's bad it's bad we
just can't talk about the last thing
they want you to know is the actual
plans of the Democratic Party
unfortunately for the Democrats some of
that was able to seep out through the
cracks despite the best attempts of
people like Rachel Maddow to prevent
people from talking about what they
would do as president of the United
States well get to more of Democratic
policy in a moment that's the stuff that
really helps from in one second but
first let's talk about the fact that it
is open enrollment season and during
open enrollment season that is the time
for you to get life insurance but the
problem is this when you get life
insurance through your employer it might
represent what 1/10 of the kind of life
insurance you actually need as a
responsible adult this is why you should
get life insurance that doesn't link to
your job and also that is sufficient to
cover you in case god forbid something
happens to you this is why you should
check out policy genius calm policy
genius is the easy way to shop for a
life insurance plan that is not tied to
your job in minutes you can compare
quotes from top insurers and find your
best price
once you apply the policy genius team
will handle all the paperwork and the
red tape the life insurance you buy
through policy genius stays with you
even if you leave your job and policy
genius can do all sorts of insurance for
you they can do home insurance and auto
insurance and disability insurance so
when you are looking at your workplace
benefits this month
make sure to double-check those life
insurance options then head on over to
policy genius com get quotes apply in
minutes policy genius is indeed the easy
way it's compare and buy life insurance
and home insurance auto insurance
disability insurance all the insurance
could possibly want need or desire check
them out at policy genius.com ok once
you get to the actual Democratic
proposals this is where things get truly
ugly so here is Joe Biden talking about
his plan for climate change and
stumbling over himself again Joe Biden
didn't lose all the commentators today
are saying Joe Biden had a rough night
Joe Biden has a rough night every night
it's called being Joe Biden and being
alive I mean last night Joe Biden
learned that he had a grandchild in
Arkansas he didn't even know about
because hunkler Biden his son his near
do well son who gets paid to sit on the
board of Ukrainian oil and natural gas
companies based on his vast experience
and doing nothing and being kicked out
of the Navy hunter Biden had contested
paternity of a child in Arkansas and it
came out yesterday that congratulations
Joe you got a grandkid right so Joe by
every night being Joe Biden is an
adventure ok so the fact that Joe Biden
didn't perform great last night doesn't
really hurt him but what does hurt the
Democrats is every time they talk about
their climate change plans they're
totally insane so here is Joe Biden
talking about climate change the
existential threat to humanity is the
number one issue and I might add I don't
really need kind of a lecture from this
from my friend while I was passing the
first climate change bill and that so
the facts said was a game changer while
I managed the ninety billion dollar
recovery plan investing more money in
infrastructure that related to clean
energy than any time we've ever done it
my friend was producing more coal mines
and produced more coal around
the world according to the press then
all of Great Britain produces huh okay
so I mean him ripping on Tom Styer ain't
gonna help him but the fact that he's
talking about like it's an existential
threat to you Manning the number-one
issue
PolitiFact coal mines come on come on
okay and that's not even as bad as as
Bernie Sanders i Bernie Sanders is the
one who's just like money is everywhere
it's everywhere it's in my pockets
it's in my pudding does money everywhere
and I would use all that money to do
many things that I would like to do
having produced zero jobs or anything of
value for my entire adult life during my
childhood perhaps I produce something
when I was a small child I made poop but
since then I have done nothing useful
and now I will take all your money and
they will throw it at the Sun I hate the
Sun it's very mean there's Bernie
Sanders what we have got to do tonight
and I will do as president is to tell
the fossil fuel industry that their
short-term profits are not more
important than the future of this planet
and by the way the fossil fuel industry
is probably criminally liable because
they have lied and lied and lied the
evidence products were destroying the
planet and maybe we should think about
prosecuting why the moon made of cheese
why why is the moon made of cheese why
is my head so shiny I don't know what's
going on I don't know we should
prosecute people who run in the oil
industry which is powering the lights in
this room we should prosecute the people
in the oil industry for having used
carbon-based fuel that has powered the
growth of the globe for the past 150
years I like pooping do you understand
like the more American see of that do
you really think that's gonna resonate
okay then we had to foreign policy and
again the policy prescriptions of the
Democrats is is totally crazy it's
totally crazy
hey the the end and what you get here is
a combination of Joe Biden has been
wrong on every foreign policy issue of
his lifetime stumbling over himself and
then you get and then you get Joe Biden
and Bernie Sanders suggesting a
middle-eastern foreign policy that makes
no
sense and also let's let's go first of
all before we get to that aspect in
foreign policy I just want to point out
what an irritating person Elizabeth
Warren is for like the 30th time okay
the reason that I say that Elizabeth
Warren is a deeply irritating human
being is because listen to this exchange
okay so this is clip 18
so Andrew yang is asked by one of the
moderators what he would say to Vladimir
Putin if he wins the 2020 election and
yang gets off a pretty good laugh line
and then listen to Warren coming from
the wings with a bat like a character
from Goodfellas and beat the joke to
death and bury it in a shallow grave in
a cornfield in Iowa I mean it's really
amazing here's here's Andrew yang giving
a funny answer an Elizabeth Warren
clubbing this joke to death like a baby
seal if you in the 2020 election what
would you say in your first call with
Russian President Vladimir Putin I'm
sorry I beat your guy
sorry it's a sorry not sorry oh my god
Elizabeth Warren you're just the worst
you're the worst people who murder jokes
are the worst kind of murderers or like
the OJ Simpson's of our world
it's just terrible terrible okay then
you get to the actual foreign policy
statements of Joe Biden and Bernie
Sanders on the Middle East and these
make no sense if you take more than half
a second to think about it makes no
sense at all none okay we'll get to all
of that in just one moment first you
need to go subscribe over at daily wire
why should you subscribe well the reason
you should subscribe is because we have
all sorts of goodies for you so for
example our Sunday special with David
Byrne Olinsky comes out this Sunday but
if you're a subscriber then you get it
on Saturday here's a little bit of what
that Sunday special sounds like all
these guys who proclaim themselves
enthusiastic defenders of reason the
Enlightenment are simply a part of a
very long judeo-christian tradition and
they are unwilling to see in their own
faces the long tendrils stretching back
into antiquity
it's a really really interesting
interview David Berlinski is a
philosopher mathematician really
interesting dude well if you are not
already subscribed you are really
missing out head on over to daily wire
comm slash subscribe for as little as
ten bucks a month you get our articles
had free access to all of our live
broadcasts our full show library select
bonus content our exclusive daily wire
app pretty great feature if you haven't
checked it out yet and if you choose the
new All Access plan you get all of that
plus the legendary leftist ears tumblr
our brand-new ask me anything style
discussion feature that allows you to
engage with our hosts and our writers
and our special guests on a weekly basis
so stop depriving yourself this is
America come join the fun over at daily
wire.com slash subscribe we are the
largest fastest core and conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
okay so Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders lay
out the Democratic foreign policy and
suffice it to say it is completely
ignorant of the situation in the Middle
East so Joe Biden is asked about his
policy on Saudi Arabia now Saudi Arabia
is a disaster area and Saudi Arabia is a
repressive Islamic dictatorship it's a
it's a horrible horrible place but it is
also true that Saudi Arabia is the
regional check on Iran which is an even
more horrible place in the sense that
Iran has regional aspirations that Saudi
Arabia does not sometimes there are no
good guys but according to the
Democratic Party the solution in the
Middle East is to defund the government
of Saudi Arabia so that presumably the
Iranians will be able to maximize their
regional power and so the Saudi
government is in danger of falling to
Islamic radicals who are more radical
than the Saudi government which is in
fact the danger in Saudi Arabia which
would be a danger to not only global oil
supply but also a danger to the region
because you have even more militant
people in charge of Saudi Arabia how do
you think that's gonna go with Iran
here's Joe Biden though suggesting that
because how Arabia is is horrible and
terrible
therefore we should think about ending
our relationship with Saudi Arabia which
would benefit Iran there's very little
social redeeming value of the in the
present government in Saudi Arabia and I
would also as point it out I would end
and the subsidies that we have and the
sale of material to the Saudis who are
they're going in and murdering children
and they're murdering innocent people
and so they have to be held accountable
okay so yeah again I'm fine with holding
the Saudis accountable but what he's
talking about is defunding the Saudis
Bernie Sanders goes even further so
Bernie Sanders is a complete loom band
not only that he's an anti Israel
radical loon bag so here's Bernie
Sanders comparing the State of Israel to
Iran and Saudi Arabia I mean totally
crazy and then suggesting that the
United States should make alliance with
Hamas Palestinian Authority and Islamic
Jihad but and then cleaning his
pro-israel because Bernie Sanders is a
crazy person and crazy human being this
is why again people who judge standing
off to the side and being not crazy is
definitely helping him here all he asked
I've been saying since the day Donald
Trump was elected all Democrats had to
be was not crazy that means the Democrat
who appears to be the least crazy is the
person with the advantage Bernie Sanders
ain't helping the case here is Bernie
Sanders clip 20 we have got to bring
Iran and Saudi Arabia together
in a room under American leadership and
say we are sick and tired of us spending
huge amounts of money and human
resources because of your conference and
by the way the same thing goes with
Israel and the Palestinians it is no
longer good enough for us simply to be
pro-israel I am pro-israel but we must
treat the Palestinian people as well
with the respect and dignity that they
deserve we're youth unemployment is 70
or 80 percent is unsustainable so we
need to be rethinking who our allies are
around the world work with the United
Nations and not continue to support
brutal dictators okay he just compared
Israel to the brutal dictatorships of
Iran and Saudi Arabia suggested that the
unemployment rate in the Gaza Strip is
not due to the fact that a terrorist
group runs the gaza strip called hamas
he blamed it on israel and then he said
he was pro-israel that's nuts
that's nuts and that's why when people
judge says stuff that's not completely
crazy he sounds like a viable
alternative so here's people who judge
talking about reprioritizing the
military budgets he's asked are you
gonna cut the military budget watch
people who to judge avoid saying he's
gonna cut the military budget now
realistically will he slash the military
budget of course he's a radical Democrat
but does he say that no because he's
actually smart enough to hide his agenda
here's people who touch on military
spending we need to reprioritize our
budget as a whole in our military
spending in particular it's not just how
much although we certainly need to look
at the runaway growth in military
spending it's also where right now we
are spending a fraction of the intention
and resources on things like the
artificial intelligence research that
China is doing right now if we fall
behind on artificial intelligence the
most expensive ships that the United
States is building just turn into bigger
targets okay so all of that is perfectly
reasonable what he is saying right there
right he sounds like the reasonable guy
on the stage and then when he gets to
the abortion issue he wasn't asked a
question about abortion but Elizabeth
Warren and Cory Booker were and they
sounded nuts right so Elizabeth Warren
is asked about abortion and she gives
the most bizarre answer on abortion that
I can remember in recent memory this is
clip 28 Warren talking about abortion
she says abortion rights are human
rights which is weird because it's the
killing of human but apparently it's a
human right to kill another human
here's Elizabeth Warren saying something
wild on abortion and if they think is
gonna win over middle of the country
voters good luck with this here is
Elizabeth Warren I believe that abortion
rights are human rights I believe that
they are also economic rights and
protecting the right of a woman to be
able to make decisions about her own
body is fundamentally what we do and
what we stand for as a Democratic Party
understand this when someone makes
abortion illegal in America rich women
will still get abortions it's just kind
of fall hard on poor women okay that's
just nonsense I'm sorry that's
ridiculous
it's ridiculous the number of abortions
in the United States per year before Roe
vs. Wade was like one one-hundredth of
the number of abortions that happened
after Roe vs. Wade and if her contention
is that poor women should have more
abortions because they need to kill
babies in order to rise on the economic
ladder that's more of a moral problem
than anything your opponents are saying
then cory booker says something even
crazier cory booker somehow links
abortion to voter suppression he
suggests that the reason that people are
pro-life in georgia is because they're
suppressing votes and that stacey abrams
is actually the governor of georgia
this is nuts okay this is crazy towns
here's cory booker joining the crazy
parade this is a voter suppression issue
right here in this great state of
georgia
it was the voter suppression
particularly of african-american
communities that prevented us from
having a governor stacey abrams right
math and this bill opposed by over
seventy percent the heartbeat bill here
proposed by over 70 percent of Georgians
is the result from voter suppression
really it's the result of voter
suppression so it's not that the State
Legislature passed a bill signed into
law by the governor all of whom were
duly elected know it was it was voter
suppression voters by the way honest I
want the ultimate voter suppression how
about the killing of potential voters
before they have a chance to be born
that seems like a pretty effective form
of voter suppression okay but in the end
in the end what is this Democratic Party
debate really about for all of these
candidates in the end it's about your
intersectional credentials and and
listening to why Democrats believe they
are qualified
president is highly highly amusing
highly amusing because their actual
qualifications are non-existent
none of them on the stage have actually
done anything other than maybe Biden
right other than Biden who actually has
been a longtime senator who worked
across the aisle on some important
issues like for example criminal justice
reform
other than Biden no one on the stage has
done a damn thing Elizabeth Warren has
never done a thing that she proposed the
consumer finance Protection Bureau and
that is one of the most unconstitutional
pieces of government in American history
Bernie Sanders been in Korea long
useless person Cory Booker was mayor of
Newark and then left before like as his
City continued to be in a state of
collapse the Peabody judge has run a
city of a hundred thousand people he won
election with 11 thousand votes Peabody
judge won election in South Bend with
fewer votes than Alexandra Ocasio Cortes
won her district in New York he is not a
that there is no electoral qualification
for people to judge so what actually
makes these people qualified and so this
is really funny so let's talk about Budi
judge right so Buddha judge is asked how
he is going to win over black voters and
basically says I'm gonna win over black
voters because I'm gay and this is
actual answer his actual answer is I'm
gonna win over black voters because I'm
gay and just like black people have been
victimized in this country I have been
victimized in this country now people to
judge cannot name an example when he was
actually victimized in this country the
only reason that he's being taken
seriously on the stage is because he is
gay if you were not gay then people to
judge would just be another well-spoken
small-town white mayor from red state
America right there are other people I
mean remember Martin O'Malley remember
Martin O'Malley in 2016
he's mayor of Baltimore white guy fairly
well-spoken went nowhere
Pete boo to judge is getting all sorts
of press specifically because there's
something unique about his candidacy in
that he is gay and he's playing on that
right here but if you're going to say
that Peabody judge is victimized in the
same way that black Americans
historically had been victimized in
America that's absolute sugar it's just
crap it's not true Mike Pence was
governor of Indiana when people who
judge came out of the closet which by
the way was only like five or six years
ago but he came out of the closet got
married to his partner chase like three
or four years ago if I'm not missing the
timeline he only came out of the closet
publicly once he was already mayor
Bend Indiana at which point Mike Pence
was like you know go and be well
basically like at no point in people who
judge his life has he faced actual
serious hardship for being a gay man in
America if he can name it I'm willing to
hear it but he certainly is not his
history is not the history of black
people in America here's people who
judge though trying to make the case
that he should be President of the
United States because he has
intersectional Valor here's clip 24 and
I care about this because well I do not
have the experience of ever having been
discriminated against because of the
color of my skin I do have the
experience of sometimes feeling like a
stranger in my own country turning on
the news and seeing my own rights come
up for debate and seeing my rights
expanded by a coalition of people like
me and people not at all like me working
side-by-side shoulder-to-shoulder making
it possible for me to be standing here
wearing this wedding ring in a way that
couldn't have happened two elections ago
lets me know just how deep my obligation
is to help those whose rights are on the
line every day even if they are nothing
like me in their experience okay that
that is a beautifully put pitch it also
happens not to be true the people who
judge has experienced serious
discrimination because he is a gay man
in America like there's not evidence of
this I'm waiting to hear the evidence of
this other than just the generalized
argument that that until 2015 Oberkfell
decision he was not he could not get a
tax break from the government for being
married civil unions were still
available in Indiana so far as I'm aware
and no one was prosecuting him for
living with another man so that none of
that was on the table in any case who to
judge his other pitch so one is that he
has special intersectional valor because
he's gay his other pitch is that he is
not wealthy not kidding this is his
actual other pitch his other pitch in
the Democratic Party it's actually a
point in your favor if you are not
wealthy so in a normal world you haven't
earned money by running a business would
be seen as a good thing in the world of
the Democratic Party it is much better
to run if you are not rich right if you
are if you are a person of middle class
or poor circumstances somehow this is a
point in your favor you should run the
entire economy of the United States from
the top down is ademma
because you are an elitist who wants to
run everybody else's life and your
experience in doing this is having no
money here is P Buddha jazz clip 31.5
basically is Peabody judge suggesting
that he is the least wealthy person on
stage and somehow this qualifies him is
more honest or something I never thought
I'd be on a Forbes magazine list but
they did one of all the candidates by
wealth and I am literally the least
wealthy person on this stage I also wore
the uniform of this country and know
what is at stake in the decisions that
are made in the Oval Office in this
situation room and I know how to bring
people together to get things done I
know that from the perspective of
Washington what goes on in my city might
look small but frankly where we live the
infighting on Capitol Hill is what looks
small okay so basically I'm not from
Washington DC I served in the military
millions of people serve in the military
thank them for their service thank you
people to judge for your service
that ain't a soul qualifier and also
you're not wealthy I love the fact that
I'm not wealthy as an actual pitch for
the presidency as opposed to a pitch for
why you should not be in charge of the
government in a normal world people who
earn lots of money in a free market
economy now be appoints in their favor
but in the Democratic Party it's
shameful to Thomas tires on the stage
because he's a billionaire but it's very
very valorous the Peabody judges on the
stage having won election by winning
like 11,000 votes in a small town in the
middle of America it's pretty important
so that's P Buddha judges bench okay
then there is Emmy Club a club guitars
pitch so her pitch we don't have the
clip of this but she actually suggested
that she should be president because
she's a woman
yeah that she's discriminated against
because she's a woman sure yeah I'm sure
it's that I'm sure it's not that foodie
judge is stolen your thunder I'm sure
it's not that your initial campaign
lunch was surrounded by stories of you
throwing binders at your aides I'm sure
I'm sure it's not that and then Cory
Booker was like yeah well I'm a Rhodes
Scholars oh my god what do you guys
applying to college these are all
qualifications to apply to an Ivy League
school none of these things are actual
qualifications to be President of the
United States it's pretty astonishing
hey Kamala Harris basically came out and
said the reason I'm qualified for
president is because I too AM
intersectional because I am a black
woman this clip 23 so again the real
pitch to the Democratic base isn't my
ideas are better or I'm going to be
unifying or I have great experience in
this job bringing people together right
most of their
we're like I'm a woman I'm gay I'm not
wealthy I'm a Rhodes Scholar pretty weak
T here's comel harris saying that the
reason that she's running is to bring
back together the Obama coalition and
apparently only an identity politics
black woman can do so clip 23 because I
believe that we have to have leadership
in this country who has worked with and
have the experience of working with all
folks and we've got to recreate the
Obama coalition to win and that means
about women that's people of color
that's our LGBTQ community that's
working people that's our labor unions
but that is how we are going to win this
election and I intend to win okay yeah
no you're not you're going nowhere
you're going nowhere my favorite was the
closure from Joe Biden on this so Joe
Biden was asked specifically about that
coalition and what are his
qualifications now his qualifications
and all of this is I'm a senator who
worked everyday for people across the
country I'm a vice president who worked
everyday with people across the country
instead Joe Biden takes one step and
immediately falls directly on his face
and breaks his nose here is Joe Biden
clip 27 explaining that he is part of
the Obama coalition a coalition I come
out of the black community in terms of
my support if you notice I have more
people supporting me in the black
community that announced from me because
they know me they know who I am
three former chairs of the black caucus
the only black American woman that ever
been elected to the United States Senate
a whole range of people
okay so there he is stumbling the only
black woman who had ever been elected to
the to the United States Senate well
yeah I mean Kamala Harris is standing
right there so well done Joe okay so in
the end here's what you have Buddha
judge didn't get even mildly grazed last
night
I mean nobody launched a serious attack
I'm the only serious attack was at one
point a me Club which are pointed out
that he has no experience and he's a
small town mayor that was it no attacks
on his plans no attack on his record
nothing so Buddha judge walks out
unscathed
Warren continues to sort of flounder
because she's got nothing Joe Biden is
an ambulance he's a dead person walking
he is he is weekend at Joe's they
they've propped him up on a gurney and
they're just walking him
at this point but everybody knows that
and Bernie Sanders continues to be crazy
so do the polls radically shift after
all of us no they don't which means
actually good news for Joe Biden and
good news for people who to judge so
those are the big winners of the night
even though Joe Biden again was
stumbling and bumbling but all of that
is baked into the cake okay time for a
quick thing I like and a quick thing
that I hate and then we will be out of
here so things that I like today there's
a great book by C Bradley Thompson
called America's a revolutionary mind
came out just a couple of weeks ago and
the book is an exploration of the
American Revolution and the philosophy
of the American Revolution what exactly
the founders were thinking on everything
from slavery to natural rights and it's
a really great compendium of the of the
thought of the founding fathers again
the book is called America's
revolutionary mind and the authors see
Bradley Thompson is well worth the rated
as a fantastic source book on sort of
the history of the American Revolution
at least he through the history of
thought surrounding the American
Revolution and it definitely gives the
lie to the idea that the founding
fathers were just a bunch of rich white
property holders who were only
interested in preserving their own spot
at the top of the hierarchy I mean if
but anybody who's read any of the
founding fathers knows that that is not
true that that is just revisionist
history this book makes that obvious see
Bradley Thompson's America's
revolutionary mind okay time for some
quick things that I hate okay so first
of all cats so cats is a is a movie
musical that is coming out it's a
horrible musical Cats I mean just in a
truly awful piece of garbage
there's certainly Andrew Lloyd Webber
musicals that are well crafted right
that are good Phantom of the Opera is
good Joseph in the in the Technicolor
Dreamcoat
is if not a great musical it has some
great stuff in it cat is just horrible
and there is always this big question on
Broderick's it ran forever why exactly
did cats do so well the answer is there
are a lot of blue hairs who have cats
and like cats and they want to hear cats
sing so the only problem with this is
when you transfer this to film it is the
creepiest crap anybody has ever seen
here's that they've released a second
trailer now now the first trailer
creeped everybody out because it was
anthropomorphic and from amorphous eyes
cats who were human beings singing to
you and it was scary and creepy like a
childhood nightmare come to life the new
on ain't gonna save you any sleep here
is here's the new cat's trailer
oh now it's the most deserving cat will
be reborn into another life so they can
be have they've always dreamed to be
what's your name cat got your tongue
[Music]
that is most important
that is that is just awful inter-cell
but what are you doing man no don't do
it don't do it and this cast is enormous
and Taylor Swift for some reason no it's
God who who thought this was a good idea
who who
I mean this movie is going to if this
movie makes money the country is done
okay I'm just gonna put it out there if
this movie does well at the box office
we deserve whatever we get including a
nuclear apocalypse this is just
horrifying Tom Hooper is a good director
gratis the guy did the King's Speech and
did lame is also lame is a pretty good
film adaptation why you would adapt cats
to screen and have Taylor Swift wearing
a bodysuit so you've got like weird sexy
and Throop amorphous eyes
cats like what is what is going on stop
it
the nightmares ah the nightmares okay
one other thing that I hate so there's a
story out today from the Census Bureau
talking about how fewer Americans are
moving than ever before according to the
New York Times Americans are moving at
the lowest rate since the government
started keeping track according to the
Census Bureau data released on Wednesday
the US has long been one of the most
mobile countries in the developed world
in the 1950s about one-fifth of the
American population moved each year
these days rents have exploded making it
much harder for young persons seeking
better opportunities to afford to move
that doesn't even make any sense if
friends have exploded it should make it
more likely that you move people
typically moved when they needed to move
now people just stick around and wait
for the government to take care of them
or suggest that their dying town is
going to suddenly be revived as long as
we tax the rich people with a wealth tax
or something it is a bad thing that
Americans are moving less than ever now
listen I live very close to where I grew
up but I left here for law school and my
wife thought that she was gonna have to
go to medical school in Washington DC we
prepped the move when I thought I was
gonna have to get a job in New York City
we prepped the move it was not
unwillingness to move is that we didn't
have to move but if we'd had to move we
would move if we have to move our entire
company will move our entire company the
fact is that willingness to move is a
good sign that you are willing to make
your life better and the fact that more
Americans are not moving at a time of
great prosperity and easy mobile
they used to take a long time to move
now you can do it like two days across
the country that is not that that shows
that there is there is something amiss
in in the way Americans are thinking
about what their lives ought to be as
I've said before the only thing you're
guaranteed in America is the adventure
if you're not gonna take advantage of
the adventure then you're missing not
only half the joy of life but you are
also missing a lot of opportunities so
you know get on your running shoes and
be willing to move if the opportunity
crops up somewhere that you don't live
alright we'll be back here later today
for two additional hours including all
your impeachment gait updates I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jessica alvera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19 on the Matt Walsh show we're
not just discussing politics we're
talking culture faith family all of the
things that are really important to you
so come join the conversation
you